KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, CONGRESSMAN JASON
CHAFFETZ, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP KEEPING SOME
PRAISE ON HIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TODAY.
PURSUING CALIFORNIA OVER ITS
SHIELDING OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> SANCTUARY CITIES.
WE ARE WORKING VERY HARD.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS DONE
A FANTASTIC JOB.
I DO THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
LEGISLATION WHERE WE PUT AN
EXTRA LINE IN THE MONEY WE GIVE
THEM.
YOU WANT THE MONEY, YOU CAN HAVE
THE SANCTUARY CITIES.
WITH THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND AND
THE OTHER DAY WAS A DISGRACE.
WHERE THEY HAD CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND PEOPLE READY TO BE
GOTTEN.
SHE WENT OUT AND WARNS THEM ALL.
SCATTERED.
INSTEAD OF TAKING IN 1,000, THEY
TOOK IN A FRACTION OF THAT VERY,
VERY DANGEROUS FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF I.C.E. AND BORDER
PATROL.
VERY DANGEROUS.
YOU REALLY MADE LAW ENFORCEMENT
MUCH MORE DANGEROUS THAN IT HAD
TO BE.
>> Dana: THE SANCTUARY STATE
LASHING OUT HARD.
>> HOW DARE YOU VILIFY MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY BY TRYING TO
FRIGHTEN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
INTO THINKING THAT ALL
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS ARE
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS TRYING
TO DISTRACT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FROM A FAILED IMMIGRATION SYSTE
SYSTEM.
BY PAINTING A RACIST BROAD BRUSH
OF OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY IS
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS.
>> IT’S A BAD IDEA FOR HIM TO
START TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THE HISTORY OF SLAVERY
OR RECONSTRUCTION OR THE CIVIL
WAR IN THE UNITED STATES.
CREDIBILITY IS PRETTY MUCH SHOT
ON THOSE ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE FUTUR
FUTURE.
AND THEY DON’T LIKE IT, BUT
THERE YOU GO.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT PLANS
TO VISIT CALIFORNIA NEXT WEEK
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OFFICE.
COULD BE AN INTERESTING TRIP,
KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: YES, OKAY, WE ARE
GOING TO IGNORE THE OBVIOUS?
WE ALL WORE BLUE IN SOLIDARITY
FOR SOMETHING WE WILL MAYBE
EXPLAIN LATER.
OR WE JUST FORGOT.
ONE OF US LOOKS LIKE A SMURF,
NOT ME.
>> Dana: ONE OF US LOOKS LIKE
GROVER.
KIMBERLY WORE IT BETTER.
>> Kimberly: WRITE US.
>> Dana: WE KNOW WHO WORE IT
BEST.
IT’S OBVIOUS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
CALIFORNIA, AND I THINK BOTH
POLITICAL BASIS, THIS IS THE
ISSUE WHERE THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO AGREE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO, AND THEY
CAN’T AGREE.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS.
CALIFORNIA, THE LEADERS, THE
GOVERNOR, AGGRESSIVE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS IMMIGRATION
POLICIES.
YOU HAVE MADE ERRORS MAKING A
PROTEST, WARNING ILLEGALS THERE
IS ABOUT TO BE A RAID.
SUING HIM ENVIRONMENT THE ABOUT
THE WALL, TAKING A LOT OF HEAT
ABOUT THAT.
EVERYBODY WAS RUNNING FOR OFFICE
FOR GOVERNOR NEXT FEELS THE SAME
WAY AND WANTS TO SUE.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
WORK OUT VERY WELL FOR THEM.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HE IS NOT
SHYING AWAY FROM ANY KIND OF
ADVERSITY.
HE’S GOING TO GO THERE AND MAKE
HIS OPINIONS KNOWN.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE
CONTENTIOUS.
THERE WILL PROBABLY PROTEST BUT
ULTIMATELY I BELIEVE HE IS GOING
TO PREVAIL ON THIS ISSUE.
>> Dana: GREG, CALIFORNIA, OF
COURSE HIS POLITICS MOSTLY LEAN
LEFT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONSERVATIVE
AND REPUBLICANS WHO LIVE THERE
THAT PROBABLY THEN AGREE THAT AT
LEAST ON THE SANCTUARY CITY
ISSUE AND MAY BE THE WALL, IT’S
A GOOD IDEA.
>> Greg: WE TOUCHED ON THIS
YESTERDAY.
IF YOU ARE A CALIFORNIAN, DO YOU
WANT YOUR FAR LEFT LEADERS TO
EQUATE THIS KIND OF ISSUE WITHIN
ISSUE THAT LED TO CIVIL WAR?
WHEN THEY ARE BRINGING UP
SLAVERY OR CIVIL RIGHTS, ARE YOU
AS A CALIFORNIAN OKAY WITH FAR
LEFT ACTIVISTS BASICALLY
DRUMMING UP AN ISSUE TO A POINT
WHERE IT COULD BE -- LEAD TO
VIOLENCE.
THAT’S NUTS.
IT’S A LITTLE BIT IRRATIONAL TO
BRING UP THESE THINGS WHEN
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT ILLEGAL
ALIENS ON FEDERAL LAW AND
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THE OTHER POINT, I SAID IF YOU
ARE OKAY WITH VIOLATING A LAW
THAT YOU DON’T LIE, THEN YOU
BETTER BE OKAY WITH ME VIOLATING
A LAW THAT YOU LIKE.
CAN I HAVE A SANCTUARY CITY FOR
OPEN CARRY OR AN ABORTION-FREE
ZONE.
WHAT WOULD TAKE OFF THE LOT?
AN ENTIRE SANCTUARY CITY FOR
UNBORN CHILDREN, A PERMIT TO
CARRY, AND COUNTRY MUSIC.
>> Dana: COUNTRY MUSIC?
>> Greg: YES, THAT WOULD DRIVE
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS.
>> Dana: I WILL LET YOU HAVE
YOUR OWN SANCTUARY CITY FOR
DEATH METAL AND NO ONE WILL COME
VISIT YOU.
IT WILL BE BETTER FOR YOU.
ARE YOU WITH ME, AMERICA?
LET ME KNOW.
JUAN, I HAD A GREAT QUESTION FOR
YOU.
I REALLY HAD A GOOD ONE.
HE THREW ME OFF WITH COUNTRY
MUSIC.
I WILL LET YOU SAY WHATEVER YOU
THINK YOU WANT TO SAY.
>> Greg: I AGREE WITH GREG,
SAYS JUAN.
>> Juan: MY THOUGHT IS THERE
ARE SO MANY LAYERS BECAUSE
PRESIDENT OBAMA SUED ARIZONA FOR
VIOLATING SOME OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT POLICIES WITH REGARD
TO IMMIGRATION, AND HE WON
BECAUSE THE COURT SAID FEDERAL
LAW, WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION, IS SUPREME AND IS
THE LAW OF THE LAND AND STATES
SHOULDN’T INTERFERE.
CALIFORNIA’S RESPONSE TO THIS IS
FOR THEY ARE NOT INTERFERING.
WHEN THEY ARE DOING UNDER THE
TENTH AMENDMENT WHICH GUARANTEES
THEM THE RIGHT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY, TAKING STEPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
AREN’T SIMPLY TRYING TO AVOID
PAYING PEOPLE BY CALLING THE
FEDS AND SAY GET THESE GUYS OUT
OF HERE BEFORE I HAD TO PAY
THEM.
OR SECONDLY, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT CRIMINALS BUT ARE IMMIGRANTS
ARE NOT ABUSE WHEN THEY ARE
DETAINED IN HOUSTON FACILITIES.
SOMETIMES FOR-PROFIT FACILITIES.
THERE’S BEEN A HISTORY OF PAST
ABUSE OF IMMIGRANTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO TALK ABOUT
SLAVERY, THAT WAS BROUGHT UP NOT
BY KAMALA HARRIS.
IT WAS BROUGHT UP A JEFF
SESSIONS WHO SAID THE SEVEN
STATES BELIEVED IN NULLIFICATION
OF FEDERAL LAW, AND THAT’S WHAT
HE SAID CALIFORNIA WAS UP TO.
I THINK THERE ARE AREAS HERE
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO NULLIFY ANY
LAW.
WE ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO PROTECT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Greg: PROTECT FROM WHAT?
>> Juan: PUBLIC SAFETY.
>> Greg: WHO IS A THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY?
>> Juan: PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN TALK TO THE COPS.
THEY CAN’T TALK TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNFAIR.